barnet hospital is what it calls full up
to the front door that means some
patients having to wait in ambulances
because there isn't room inside
patients like ray who's hurt is coccyx
in a fall
how long have you been waiting in the
ambulance for
i probably think maybe an
hour i mean it is frustrating because i
want to go in there yesterday was very
busy 42 people waiting for beds
in
a e waiting for beds in the morning
which means people like paul raymond
here get stuck outside and then we're
having to treat people in the ambulance
it's not fair he's in a lot of pain and
all we've got is gas and air at the
moment for him frustrating for you to
not be able to offer the you'd like very
frustrating yeah
as we talk another ambulance arrives and
if these vehicles can't offload quickly
they're not available for further call
outs you might have five or six
ambulances waiting 60 minutes or longer
and cumulatively that time across london
is ginormous and the worry is around the
uncertain risk
of that patient has dialed 999 or
somebody star 99 and that that ambulance
cannot get to them in a timely way we've
got a huge demand for beds at the moment
so how to ease the pressure the adult
assessment unit next to a e is usually
short stay but is adapting into a ward
to create more bed space these are the
pressure mattresses that we need for our
patients
um so i've just been to the site team um
and escalated the fact is that we need
another nine pressure mattresses this
isn't normally a ward this is no no this
is not this is aau so aau is an
assessment unit so some people having to
stay here essentially because you
haven't got anywhere else to put them
well yes
that yes
there's not just a shortage of beds but
also staff nationally nhs absences have
gone up nearly 60 in a week and it's the
same here in the emergency department
we've had another doctor calling in sick
for next week already
we're pretty much hemorrhaging doctors
um every day and next week basically
we're down to three night doctors
as it stands
which is going to be rather difficult so
three out of seven doctors
the emergency department has been just
overloaded with patients we've had
no exit flow through
to the wards upstairs with ambulances
having to queue outside over the past
few days we've had weights of up to up
to eight hours nine hours to to see a
doctor especially at night time
seventy-seven-year-old alan has been
admitted with a heart condition he
should be on a ward but after 20 hours
he's still in a e and he blames people
who've not been vaccinated taking up
space what they don't understand is that
they it isn't just a question of
protecting themselves they're being
selfish because they're taking up beds
that need not be taken up and that is
putting more pressure on the health
service
here on the covered wards they say a few
months ago they had many serious
unvaccinated young people with the delta
variant now there are more elderly
vaccinated people with omicron our award
is a 35 bedded board which was purpose
built during the pandemic to look after
patients with covet
currently our bed ward is full and it's
full with all patients with
omicron symptoms seem milder but people
are still getting dangerously ill 38
year old julia ally who twice booked and
then cancelled her vaccination
contracted covid at a christmas party
i understand you haven't had the vaccine
is that right that's correct yes yeah
why didn't you
take the vaccine with all those social
media controversy so that kind of
made me think
is it right or is it wrong it's the
biggest regret
i should have listened to all my like
family and friends because everybody
else has had it it's just me
did you feel like you were gonna die i
did
must have been terrified before i even
got here at home when the ambulance came
up i was on my last breath my oxygen was
below 70.
yeah so i was quite close to death
covid impacts everything in the
geriatric ward some patients can't leave
because of staff shortages in social
care or some can't be discharged because
one person on their ward tested positive
what it means is that this base now
shuts probably for the next two weeks
while we wait for the remaining patients
to
go through a period of isolation
we can't admit any new patients into
this bay until it's been cleared
cleaned and is ready to receive patience
again one of those who would otherwise
be discharged is keith mckenzie who just
wants to get home i was sort of kind of
stuck in a nightmare
yeah
and that perhaps sums up the nhs right
now a series of bottlenecks with some
patients unwillingly stuck here and
others held up from even getting through
the door jason farrell sky news